last time we looked at basic sentences
in Volger latin and romance simple
sentences have one finite verb which
means a verb with person number endings
these contrasts with non-finite forms
like this infinitive in Romance grammar
a clause is a chunk of language
revolving around one finite verb
acanthus de que si la varita Malouda
case these are all clauses that you've
seen
we can't they say t can't quote they say
that Cantus bene
you sing well he can't quote can't as
been a Dinka Kant has been the you incur
Cantor's Bay Iggy's could shot beer for
they say that you sing well the mood of
the second verb can power in this
example will be subjunctive instead of
indicative if the first verb has a whiff
of the counterfactual about it
volula Cantus I want that you sing where
you may or may not sing verses Sofia
will contest I know that you sing where
you are definitely singing Romanian uses
the word son to connect the two finite
verb and the verb after saw is always
subjunctive Pinta
she sings Fidel I want browser content
literally I want that she sings notice
the structure of sentences like I want
that you sing in romance in English this
is normally I want you to sing with an
infinitive to sing why the difference
the subjects of the two verbs are
different ago volio I want to Cantus you
sing so they're attached with quote or
romance
okay.come or key but this verbs in the
subjunctive there that gives us the
right sentence
when the subjects of the two verbs are
the same like a Cavalia and echo canto
the second one's left as an infinitive
they go valio can't re and not a Koval
Yoko take Oconto so bull can't are
irrational tea will you can't re
that's the difference between what to
sing and what that somebody sing but
this isn't true of Romanian where two
verbs with the same subject can still
join throw I want Brown second which
literally means I want that I sing modal
verbs are normally found before an
infinitive with this finite plus
infinitive structure Basu Cantara
Deb you can't re classical Latin had
passive endings for verbs can taught
sings but can taught or it is some those
passive endings didn't survive but that
doesn't mean the modern languages avoid
passives they've created other ways of
expressing the same thing here's one
we've seen if you recall as said a with
a past participle esta can't Otto s
scripted illu libras scripto extremely
common in romance is the use of
reflexive say with third-person verbs
can taught well you know what that means
by now say can taught literally it sings
itself for it is some scree bit
Cesc leave it literally it writes itself
for it is written the verbs number
singular plural matches the number of
the subject Allah Lee Bruce is gribbit
the book is written by los libros
agreement the books are written this
passive with Saif is heard across the
romance-speaking world from Romania to
Portugal a few languages have generic
third-person pronouns that can
approximate a passive French assault
romance in tanta uniquely inch cleaver
French leans heavily on this way of
forming the passive we've run through a
range of sentence types to give you a
feel for romance syntax we've now seen
the basics of how nouns verbs pronouns
adjectives adverbs and sentences work in
Vulgar Latin and the Romance languages
thank you for taking the time to learn
with me